citizens of reject nation we are back with post
comic con coy's comic corner you may notice all
those c have a little gravel to them because your
boy koi khan so crud and hard i hosted hall age
i did my first ever hall age i hosted a comic
book in all age the first host to host to comic
con hall h and i had an amazing panel with jim
starlin an amazing panel wv games and just general
comic-con merriment when you add all those things
together you have no more voice so i do apologize
for the gravel in my voice that said please do
leave a like leave a comment notify yourself by
hitting that bell up there and subscribe to us
i have a ton more video ideas i want to bring to
you and that brings me to the comments please
do comment below what you want to see more of
we just got an onslaught for a lot more marvel
content to come and i want to know what you want
to hear about most please do follow me on tik tok
i do 15 second 30 second one minute three minute
videos over there and i'm gonna be doing a whole
bunch talking about all of this stuff to come i'm
trying to crank out like three or four videos a
day this video is going to be about phase five
and six's marvel announcements so far that does
mean i'm not going to be including she-hulk and
wakanda forever in this particular video you all
know how excited i am for shield that comes out in
just a couple of weeks and i will say briefly
that wakanda forever trailer i knew would be
beautiful i knew it'd be mesmerizing i didn't know
how brutal that would feel it was such a stunning
experience of seeing that trailer and seeing it
in hall h with that crowd i'd been crying all
throughout the whole age panel um because it was
all so emotional but that that particular trailer
resonated in a way i didn't think i'd feel from
a trailer and it's just mesmeric and wonderful
so we'll kind of forever would be so high up
on this list if it was phase five or six well
connor forever is not on this list because we're
gonna do phase five and six let's kick it off
number 15 and you guys are gonna hate me and
you're gonna leave a lot of comments and i know
it's coming but i am genuinely excited
for all these this is just the one i'm
least of the excitement and
that is echo i really really
enjoy the character of echo i think she is
fascinating i think she is important but
as per the movies and shows we have so far
lowest on the list i did enjoy her portrayal
in hawkeye but i never found myself going like i
need more of her whereas the top 14 i genuinely
cannot wait to see each of these characters again
so echo by default is on the lower side that said
we don't have a single trailer yet if the trailer
comes out and that changes that would change this
whole thing but having it be the unknown having
it be the least of my pulls number 15. number 14
was agatha all along number 14 is going to be the
agatha harkness show which i am very excited about
especially since i do think it involves dr doom
in a way there's a certain other elements some
mysticism but that's another video uh that said i
do think agatha harkness is a really interestingly
duplicitous character i think catherine hahn had
a lot to do in wanda vision she was able to add
a lot of heart to this character i'm a big fan
of the character bag of darkness because she's
from salem mass i'm a massachusetts kid and i
do think the way catherine han portrayed her
was even more interesting than some of her comic
book counterparts ability to really bring that
multi-faceted element but that said as far as a
show i want to see more of her i'm just not sure
what they're going to do with that character we
haven't seen a trailer we haven't seen any of this
so currently it's low just because i don't know
which direction they're taking her inner solo
number 13 is iron heart and this one is this
high on the list almost completely because of
the actress playing riri williams she was rigory
williams on that stage the moment she spoke
at hall h i was like that's riri i literally
tweeted out oh my god she sounds exactly like
riri her word choices the cadence in her speech
sounded like how i imagined bendis the entire aura
she brought to the character has that incredible
slightly smart alecky smart snarky smart like
there's a certain nest to how she's got little
verbal barbs and there's this confidence in the
way she carries herself i was so impressed with
this actress i actually met her at a party after
later that night and we talked about bendis and
the way she feels about that almost shakespearean
there's almost an amic pentameter to the way that
she and rigri williams speak this is a show i'm
very excited about i cannot wait to see ironheart
come to life big fan of this comic big fan of
this actress already overjoyed to see this on the
screen my number 12 is captain america new world
order now i am excited for this because i'm really
enchanted by the idea of seeing a different take
on captain america i really enjoy the sam wilson
captain america comics i think they're gonna go
with probably a moral militant police force
there's a whole thing about a new world order
in the comic books involving a very authoritative
police force i think where this ties into phase
four leading into five where we're seeing a lot
of the department of damage control we're we're
seeing a lot of almost fascist government things
in the comic books i think we're gonna get more
and more authoritative in the comic books i think
this captain america movie's gonna take that on
the head i don't necessarily think we're getting
a multiversal cap i think this is our sam wilson
i don't think we're getting hydra steve rogers
because there's no way that that chris evans
sullies his captain america by coming back to play
a villain i don't see either of those happening
personally if chris evans gets a script that's
really strong for hydrocap maybe but i think the
way he sees his arc is done it's solved it's it's
everything it's over that being said i do think
an aggressive police force versus what it would be
like to see sam wilson in the role of cap is much
more interesting commentary in the world today and
it mirrors the sam wilson captain america comics
better and it allows for a lot more of the new
falcon to do post falcon in the winter soldiers so
this is one i'm really excited for following
up that show which i do think is a bit slept on
as well as the world we're living in today as well
as the comics that i love very much number 11 i
am so very excited for this because of the end
of miss marvel i think we're going to have such
a good time seeing miss marvel interacting with
captain marvel interacting with spectrum or photon
whichever name they go with for that incredible
portrayal of the character i think the three of
them are gonna have an amazing time i think we're
gonna have some cosmic high jinks i think we're
gonna have some developments earthbound as far as
the development of what the dodc is does leading
up to thunderbolts i think we're gonna have a lot
of really interesting cosmic meeting earthbound
dynamic and the way we have aman valani playing
ms marvel as this incredible fanboy of the marvel
universe is going to be beautifully reflecting
captain marvel's stoic-ness i think we're finally
going to find a way to make the brie larson
captain marvel as dynamic as i know brie larson
playing captain marvel can be the more we've seen
her play this character post captain marvel the
more have been endeared to her i love brie larson
i want to see the miss marvel captain marvel that
i think amman and brie can do plus nina acosta
directed the hell out of a movie that i really
loved called candyman the visual aesthetic that
style she's already filmed the post-credits scene
of miss marvel i'm already intrigued by this new
costume this new flavor of brie larson's move plus
nida costa directing this is very high up on my
list i know the number 11 doesn't seem high but
that's because we're at peak height number 10 this
one is high because i finally saw some footage of
it and the footage looked so good ant-man and
the wasp quantum mania i've been saying for a
very long time is going to be a much bigger movie
impact-wise for the mcu than ant-man one and two
they very consciously seem to make the ant-man
movies short of a post-credits scene kind of over
here like they they have scott lang who's you know
he's fine but in the avengers ant-man the other
ant-man hank pym was a founding member he's a very
important character i could see this movie being
as essential to the avengers films going forward
as your iron mans and your captain america's i
think this movie is going to be essential because
it brings us kang there's a reason this kicks off
phase five i think the reason we're shaping phase
five the way we are is kang we know that's heading
towards phase six the use of kang in this movie
plus how stunning visually this looked i talked
to peyton reed and some of his influences and
style choices and everything he's building here
are art it looks astounding there is so much
scope there's so much humor there's so much of
the things we love about the first two but adding
avengers level scope means i think we'll get
everything i love about ant-man plus everything
i love about the iron man and avengers movies
in one beautiful package i think a lot of people
are gonna be surprised at how much they're gonna
love quantum mania and the footage was amazing
number nine thunderbolts thunderbolts is so so
so high on my list because i think it is so so so
important i've been saying all over ms marvel that
thunderbolts is going to be a big shift in the mcu
i think there's a reason thunderbolts ends phase
5. this is going to be an avengers level event
this is avengers but dark this is a dark avengers
film and that's effectively the combination of two
books i think they're making this movie out to be
we need going forward in the mcu to distrust
heroes the universe needs to distrust heroes
we're gonna love them but we need to have the
world where we can have the x-men that are hate
and fear we can have different dynamics of why
heroes need masks the comic books are getting more
and more represented in the costumes we're getting
more and more accurate to storyline distrust of
heroes because of things like secret invasion
and thunderbolts you're going to see a lot of
the population start to distrust these characters
because of secret invasion because we're going to
find out a lot of heroes are revealed to be aliens
then in thunderbolts that's all gonna come to
a head when a team of avengers is revealed to be
evil this thunderbolts movie is the way that phase
six happens in my opinion i'm wondering if by the
end of this they have to go back in time using
kang stuff to even fix the opinion of yours i
think thunderbolts is going to be enormous i think
it's going to be a giant 250 plus million dollar
movie i think the scope is going to be absolutely
insane and it's something we haven't really seen
before i think thunderbolts is the closest to an
avengers level event that we have in phase five
and i think that it's going to surprise a lot of
people this one's my number nine number eight loki
season two the sequel to my favorite of the marvel
shows so far this show is hard to even explain why
i'm excited because it's just based off how much i
loved season one we don't know where it's gonna go
the tva is kind of in a state of flux whether or
not it even exists like what's that gonna be we've
seen some like behind the scenes footage looks
like loki goes mcdonald's like what is happening
what i know is that justin and aaron uh justin
benson and aaron moorhead are making a show and
that's following up on their incredible visual
style and aesthetic and all of their properties
most recently moon knight that is going to be
tiny why me insane and that we're getting
mobius back just the knowledge we're gonna
get another existential crisis of a show with
tom hiddleston and owen wilson is enough the
fact that the first season was so good puts this
really high up for me but the fact that we don't
really know what it's about and the fact that
kang is so formative to where we're going it's
going to involve time travel it's going to involve
kang and maybe traveling through time i theorize
it's going to be them kind of chasing the threads
of what kang has undone i think kang is going to
be a behind the scenes manipulator all theory
that they're going to have to solve a lot of
the problems of showing us just how big of a bad
he is again conjecture theory but no matter what
even if it doesn't involve kang it's a sequel to
that incredible season of television that i cannot
wait for number seven might have the hardest
task of anything in this video number seven
is not an avengers property which sounds like it'd
be hard number seven is not a sequel to a property
that's beloved which sounds like it is hard this
is a reboot of wesley snipes's blade that series
is near perfect i love the blade movies the blade
movies are how the mcu exists it is a very very
hard bite to chew and do it right that's a bad
metaphor but i was thinking of a vampire thing
my point is they have a lot to chew this is big
this is enormous and mahershala ali is one of
the best to do it so if anyone can he can i'm so
excited for this i cannot imagine a more difficult
way to launch into the supernatural because we're
all going to be wanting this to be as good as the
og blade but that means if it does succeed if it's
as good as the old blade was and ties into the mcu
if it's able to be this incredible vampire world
that incorporates all the supernatural leading to
the midnight suns which is what i think it's going
to be and brings us a blade that we love as much
as wesley snipes this will be one of the all-time
great mcu properties this says the hardest thing
to do but it has the most potential to be the
best all the ingredients are there all the hype
is there all of the want is there i think blade is
going to be very special number six guardians of
the galaxy three i love these two movies so much
and the first one is in my top four mcu films i
am obsessed with the world james gunn has built
i saw the new trailer at comic-con it broke me
it is so emotional it is so visually stunning
it is riveting it was just such a kick in the
stomach and i think high evolutionary personally
maybe spoilers theories this is i don't know but i
think high evolutionary is going to be responsible
for making rocket raccoon i think this is going
to be a movie about the saddest creature in the
universe rocket and i think we're going to see
the horrors of how he came from and i think the
guardians as a family are gonna be wanting revenge
on that character and i think it's gonna be a
really brutal revenge tale where our hero's gonna
have to do awful things i think high evolutionary
is gonna be a terrifying villain i think the use
of james gunn and the way he sees the world we're
gonna see some horrific things we're gonna see
animals mutated human sentient beings as well as
animals just be manipulated into being evolved and
i think that's an interesting commentary on on our
real world atrocities the way people see things as
involved the way people see things as beneath them
i think this villain might not be as big as an
overarching villain as kang but i think it might
be the most traumatic villain to the viewer and
i think our empathy for groot and rocket and the
rest of the guardians is really going to be tested
when this all falls apart and i think a lot of
people are going gonna die i think this movie
might be the most brutal movie in the mcu and
i'm very excited for it in a very bittersweet way
because it does end our guardian saga but it looks
perfect this trailer is everything so it's high up
number six is guardians number five is fantastic
for full disclosure we usually do all these in
one take but this is the second take as i started
explaining why i'm excited fantastic four and i'm
actually gonna make that another video i've got so
many things to say about doctor doom then that's
gonna be a separate video please watch it this
week that said fantastic four i'm excited about
because i think this is the best opportunity to
find the best things of the other fantastic four
movies use all of those like how cinematic these
characters are human torch thing sue storm mr
fantastic are all very visually appealing there's
a reason this is one of the first superhero teams
to do as well this character set has been around
since the beginning of marvel this is marvel's
first family both in title and reality this is
an important set of characters that haven't been
done right i think they know how important this
is i think they're investing so much into this
entire world i think there's a reason it's
coming in phase six again there's gonna be a
doctor doom video but most of all i think this is
the marvel chance to make something that feels new
while still being a team i think this could be
very heartwarming and endearing and different and
wholesome and i don't think we've seen anything
quite like the comic book fantastic four in any
superhero universe this has a lot of expectations
but if it lands it's gonna be really really
important to the greater mcu i'm very excited for
my hope for the fantastic four number four secret
invasion this is probably the biggest leap up in
expectation to delivery i really didn't expect a
ton from segan invasion i like the comic i don't
love the comic it's beloved by many it's just not
one of my favorites the art is gorgeous the story
is a lot of fun it's very conspiratorial but it
never landed for me the same way it has for a lot
of other people again i love a lot of the factors
of it but it's not one of my all-time greats that
said the trailer they showed us the footage we saw
is every bit the 70s espionage thriller that
i love about winter soldier but with even
more paranoia with even more a sense of ominous
doom everything about this show looks incredible
that the stacked cast looks like it's going to
deliver really well they didn't even have to show
a scroll really in the secret invasion footage to
have me absolutely invested and it also looks to
kind of walk that line between r-rated and pg-13
in a way that daredevil did on netflix this show
looks genuinely and i hate that these are buzz
words because it kind of eliminates the hype
generally dark gritty and adult in all the ways
i want to see the difference of these shows being
this feels like a show you could watch with your
grandparents just like the redford element of
winter soldier this footage really impressed
me it was actually my number one takeaway from
the entire hour at hall h was how much i was
surprised that secret invasion kind of became
my most anticipated show this one's really high
for a reason big expectations on this number four
secret invasion number three is the just recently
announced kang dynasty avengers kang dynasty
this could be every bit the insane time travel
elements we had with in-game but on the scale
of something we've never even seen before arguably
obviously end game is giant scale but with kang
it's infinite possibility there's so much they can
do and i think as we evolve with the surrealistic
images of multiverse of madness plus the insane
creative visual choices of love and thunder
we're gonna get more and more dynamic and more
and more comic book accurate these visuals and
the fact that kang dynasty happens in like two and
a half years there's so much between now and then
where we can evolve not just the visual aesthetic
of the mcu but also kang we're gonna see a ton of
kang leading up to this and more importantly
we're gonna see a ton of kangs we're gonna see
lots and lots of different takes on jonathan
major's character and we're gonna see how that
interweaves into this whole tapestry and i think
this is going to be part one of two of the movies
that everyone from die hard marvel fans to casual
fans that want to see all these cameos alike
get to have this is the cake and eat it two movie
part one of two cannot wait for it number two and
the reason for this shirt daredevil born again
we've now seen a flash of the yellow suited
daredevil in that she-hulk footage we have seen a
taste of kingpin that to be honest i didn't love
the delivery of as much as i've loved other things
but i think that marvel listens kevin feige knows
exactly what fans want the marvel industry listens
to these message boards and videos like this
where they know we want these changes i think when
we get kingpin back for a whopping 18 episodes
we're gonna have the kingpin we want from netflix
i think when we get matt murdock back for more
than just a beautiful wonderful uplifting cameo
no way home for 18 episodes especially after i
assume his appearance in both she-hulk and another
few properties we've had charlie cox say over and
over again this is something that's going to be
happening for years that plus the announcement of
the number of episodes plus where this falls
in the mcu plus it being born again plus the
expectations from the netflix show you ended
the netflix season 3 with a very catholic guilt
reborn already born again is a beautiful comic
arc and he's born again within marvel i love
all of this i love the expectation i love the
potential i love the daredevil netflix show
if this can be even 75 as good for that kind
of run time this is gonna be a really special
property number one and looks like phase six's end
game it looks like we're gonna have a kang dynasty
followed up by secret wars secret wars i think
is gonna be the culmination of not just these
four five and six phases i think this is gonna
be a phase one through six culmination this
concludes the multiverse saga i think it's
gonna include everything from the multiverse
i think this could have all the characters from
fox we want all the characters from sony that we
want different interpretations of the characters
within the mcu the multiverse of madness delivered
on the multiverse in that section it gave us
that wonderful john krasinski cameo it gave us
a captain carter it gave us all these things
we've always wanted to see secret wars can do that
to a grander scale an enormous scale it can
do that throughout and the story can be rich
because all three of the secret wars mini series
are so different so effective so psychedelic so
vast and it's going to be i think the kang to
doom thanos situation i think we're gonna see
you know what i'm gonna save that that's gonna go
in the doom video but i do think we're gonna see
lots and lots of elements that are part one and
part two and part two might be the biggest marvel
movie to date i think secret wars could be an
absolutely enormous undertaking if they deal with
all the time travel in the kang dynasty where
i think we're gonna land at the end of seeker
wars is gonna be very very special and i think
we're gonna have six different phases of build
up where end game was built up from three phases
and 12 years this could be built up from almost
20 years of movie making i think it comes out
in three years for a reason i think we're going
to have to put a lot of things together to
make this work and kevin feige looks at a 10
year plan he's probably calling actors from fox
and sony right now to cook it up up this insane
mega event movie the likes of which we've never
seen in a film before i think this is going to
make that endgame scene with avengers assemble
feel like the civil war scene when you look
back on it very beautiful very intense a a double
page spread come to life but comparatively small
in-game is the biggest thing we've ever
experienced in movies in this genre to date
i think secret wars is gonna make that look
small and that is saying a lot i also am really
invested in whether or not it's the russos it's
my number one because just those two words secret
wars are something comic fans have always wanted
to hear throwing avengers on top of that this is
literally everything it is my number one most
anticipated and to be honest i'm glad it's so
far away we need fantastic four first we need
everything we know of in phase four and after
the events of d23 they're gonna be filling out
that phase six board and we're gonna have a
better idea what secret wars is gonna be and i
cannot wait to dive into that when it happens
this has been my most anticipated 15 properties
of phases five and six once we get to d23 we're
gonna like i said no a not more but until then
this is where i'm at what are you most excited
about which of these properties is your number
one most anticipated again not best not favorite
what has you the most excited let me know in
the comments let me know if any of these 15
are something you'd like me to dive into more and
talk about more and let me know what theories you
have below thank you very much reject nation i
am honored to be a citizen as well as someone
speaking to you about all of this comic book
glory go read some comics please for me the books
they're so special try them out you might
dig them as much as i do all right much love
you